well kirsten covet 19 took the lives of  more than 77  000 people in december making it the  deadliest month  so far the total death toll has  surpassed 351 thousand  that's more than any other country now  this as the vaccine rollout starts to  pick up speed and tries to make up  ground  in los angeles for example the nation's  largest coronavirus hot spot  one in five people is now testing  positive for covet 19  and more than 7 thousand are  hospitalized icus are  feeling too basically filled up to  capacity and some hospitals have set up  tents outside to help handle the surge  this is the worst medical disaster that  i've seen in over 30 years of practicing  in emergency medicine  well about 4.2 million have been  inoculated far short of the 20 million  promised  by the trump administration now the head  of the federal government vaccine  distribution is proposing  cutting the modern vaccine in half to  speed up the rollout  the fda will meet this week to consider  the idea